company makes meet you give me one
factor yeah I'm doing really well how
was your weekend it was good good man
family ah [ __ ]
wait a base we have baseball we had a
birthday party for my little guy right
and it was [ __ ] yeah you guys have a
bully girl we do but my wife decided it
wasn't a pool party which I don't know
wasn't necessarily the smartest move for
our career but um but uh it was [ __ ]
hot yeah it was gonna be really good
look what you do on to flash flash here
ever been it's like a waterpark run
along now do you know what's so funny
about that this is not a joke I think I
like water parks more anything on our
aura like wet and wild yeah it's like my
favorite place on earth everybody know
where is it Long Island Riverhead
how far is up in the Hamptons like an
hour push split foot I'm gonna take my
kids there yeah it's probably supposed
to be one of the better you enjoyed it
yeah been done before Oh God
yes yeah so tell me about yourself what
are you doing here oh I guess yeah
really enjoying it I'm excited about
that new transference of yep oh just to
keep learning and wrong take no more
good how'd you get here like over the a
digitally yeah Wow
and I actually work with on my house
Jacob Harlan yep yeah here's my oh very
good front but I work there I know about
you every child linked them away you leg
yeah good for you brother how long you
been here for awhile four months yeah
how's it going I'll wait okay how's the
culture yeah good good you go my teams
ready we all support each other
we've been bringing you value yeah it's
bad it was a lot he's a good beer yeah
everyone on our team super supporters
love it yeah and so uh tell me a little
bit more about yourself Long Island yeah
Wow
what are you into no that's a bad horse
back riding that's talking to you yeah
good for you man I'm here to please my
Quesada that could shake breathing Hana
I'm awesome and good for you yeah
siblings no solo yeah lovely oh yeah
very cool yeah I think I can answer for
you um no I mean what do you think I
could do friends value I have a really
good answer
asking questions and then listening to
the answers I think a lot of people were
scared to ask like it's scary to ask
what may seem like something you think
he thinks you should know is the biggest
thing that holds people back deploying
enough humility to ask the question is
the game it's I'm actually giving you a
piece of advice that I wish I took when
I was younger I too much pride in
thinking I knew too many people here
just yet thing like yeah
got it yo I know right the number one
thing you can do by bringing value is
actually closing the gap on anything you
don't know and you do that by asking you
know and I would just form more
relationships I think one of the biggest
mistakes youngsters are making here is
we have such a nice culture so you go
and you you hold me up with super cozy
but there's all these other people like
where's your relationship like you
should ask Jo Cutrone for 15 minutes
seems scary but not not here not in the
world where I do it got it do it it
seems weird or on the creative side
hitting up Todd Bradley being like hey
Can I grab ten minutes with you and just
it seems tough but it's the number one
[ __ ] game and if you like if you feel
like in a couple months you're still not
doing it and you think about this you're
on the train like Sheree said for me to
do
that I haven't done it if you need me to
help I will and I've done it a couple
times some people have just been like
two introverted or didn't think it was
appropriate I'll do it for you
I'll send emails to pin suit and be like
hey Jo mag for 15 minutes yeah all right
sorry for you I'm good for now man I'm
uncomfortable with like asking for stuff
I like giving more but you know but
being a part of the culture bringing
people value being good dude being
patient humble but confident work hard
those with good traits no pleasure man I
wish you well thank you thank you my mom
I will I'm going to do it I'm actually
gonna literally text my wife right now